they love using logical excuses like I
need to focus I'm like cool knock
yourself out I'll talk to you in 36
months when you're crying you're
focusing on losing the lack of humility
and the lack of interest in putting in
the work on the new thing because you
just figured out the last thing is why
most people don't grow there's not an
accident that I've been winning on every
platform for the last 15 years it's
called humility and hard work you think
I was pumped when Tick Tock came along I
was dominating the gram the lack of
humility and the lack of like I don't
want to learn this new thing I just got
this that's fine there's a problem
though what you want has nothing to do
with what the market is doing the market
doesn't give about your feelings the
Market's not like oh Tyrone spent a lot
of time on Instagram we should not
create Tick Tock you think God's
thinking like that get the [__] out of
here
[Music]
Gary that's a great lead-in
is hilarious especially within social
you won on you for you one on Instagram
doing that to the person that was
holding on to Twitter or Facebook but
then you're mad when tick tock's doing
it to you the hypocrisy is deafening